hey Traders it's Mike from order Falls
and welcome back to my channel you know
in today's video I'm going to talk about
stopping volume uh what it is how to see
it in the orderflow now if you've been
enjoying my videos be sure to subscribe
to the channel and hit the like button
below so um you know you'll be notified
anytime we post a new video so stopping
volume what is it well it's a
significant increase in trading volume
that's strong enough to Halt then
potentially reverse price movement it's
called stopping volume because it
suggests that trading activity or the
increased trading activity has the power
to stop or change the direction of price
now think of it like um you know sort of
running into a brick wall right where
there's liquidity in the market to
absorb whatever aggressive buying is
taking place in the market basically to
soak it all in and then you know once
that buying has stopped because the
strong passive Traders have absorbed all
that buying what's left for the market
to do well think about it you removed
the aggressive buying from the market so
now naturally the market should reverse
it should go lower just as if a market
was selling off strongly and it R ran
into some strong resting liquidity at a
price level and that liquidity was
enough to absorb all the aggressive
selling that was taking place in the
market then what's going to happen once
that pressure of selling is removed from
the market well naturally the market
should Rally from that level now what
we've done with uh order flows Trader 8
is we've added a tool to actually help
you identify it there and you can see
you have two ways to visualize it the
the easy way is down here on the bottom
we put it down here a percentage and
what we're doing is we're calculating
the volume that's trading in a bar um is
it strong enough to represent stopping
volume and usually you're going to have
a certain threshold in mind now remember
right when dealing with volume no pun
intended it's volume related so you know
there's going to be a difference whether
you're you're looking at you know the
stopping volume to during normal trading
hours um you know like the US hours or
you know evening hours Asian hours or
you know the the sort of that little
shoulder period between the Asia close
and the European open when when volume
seems to dry up you know volume picks up
again during the European session in
certain markets but again you know
anything that you're looking at volume
related um you know you want to make
sure that there's enough volumes that
you can make a good accurate uh read on
the market okay so we have it down here
and you just to make it a lot easier
I'll just show you here you know this is
one of the reasons why I created the
orderflows trader eight software is
because you know I like to look at
different things in the order flow and
it's just amazing you know what you
could have the software do so that's why
we've added it in here and here stopping
volume right it's under the indicator
settings um it's always going to appear
down at the bottom okay but if you want
to sort of add it onto the chart itself
the footprint sort of have a Zone drawn
out if you like um you can you can do
that and you could set your volume
stopping volume strength 30 is is a good
number for most markets you know in some
other markets that are thinner this is
eurocurrency um you know maybe you're
going to want to set it at a higher
strength meaning you know there's a
greater concentration of volume coming
in in that bar you know so maybe 50% or
you know I I don't think you really need
to go below 30% maybe 25 be about as low
as I would go and just click apply so
it's still going to appear down here at
the bottom if you just want to read it
manually but if you want to sort of have
it plotted whoops on your chart right
here bearish bearish bearish um you know
bullish all these blue lines are bullish
ones from earlier you know it just makes
reading the order flow in my opinion a
lot easier you can see there's some
stopping volume starting to come in
right here some more coming in here
another one here you know as this Market
is going up and basically you know when
when you're looking
at a uh something that's going to
potentially reverse the I say reverse
the market but you know I'm looking at a
one minute chart now let's let's be
honest you know are you going to get a
major reversal from a one minute you
know if you're trading a one minute
chart you're not swing trading you are
trading sort of I say in the moment but
you know on a much shorter time frame
you could actually use this on you know
5 minute charts I honestly I don't look
Beyond 15 minute charts as as an
orderflow Trader and again you know you
want to be trading in the direction of
the market okay because you know
basically at the end of the day you know
when you think of stopping volume I in
its purest sense it should be a reversal
signal but if the market is moving in a
direction what do you have taking place
well you have if the market is going
down what you have is distribution right
strong sellers coming in strong sellers
coming in on the way down which is what
you want to see just as if the market is
going up so let's take a look here we
can uh actually adjust it a couple ways
right there's a couple different ways
you can use this Beyond just the raw
numbers I mean you could just look at
the numbers down here as one way or you
can use uh where is it here stopping
volume you could use the swing filter
okay so if I'm going to enable the swing
filter so if I want to see stopping
volume at say swing highs or swing lows
I can adjust the swing period this would
be um you know a period to five you
could adjust it if you want it Greater
you know 30 um you know
20 but five is is a good default level
and you just click apply okay so now
obviously by looking at swing highs or
swing lows you're not going to get as
many but you can see there was a nice
beautiful one here right coming in at
the swing low this was stopping volume
as a reversal sign right so if you want
to use it as a reversal tool you're
going to use the swing filter okay okay
um if you want to you know there's one
from way earlier you could use it in
moves right because again remember if
you have a move
underway and you sort of have that um
accumulation coming in right that the
strong support in the market to prevent
it from going
lower well then you know that that's
going to be a strong momentum move so
you could use it with momentum okay so
here momentum filter and you know this
is one of the new tools on here that we
have on orderflows Trader is actually
the uh momentum strength one is the
lowest six is the highest you know three
is sort of mid momentum I guess but you
know I'll just keep it at three here
just to show you you know depending on
the market that you're trading its
volatility you know you're going to you
you may want to um adjust that again
that's going to be um your
decision so you could see here you know
on this you know the move down now as
the move is going up you see the suppor
of buying here here you know a little
bit of selling then more supportive
buying starts reversing Here There and
again you know right now as this Market
is um rallying and again you know like I
said just you know remember it is a
volume based
tool so what that means is if say for
example um you know I change it to a
eight like an eight range chart okay
again this is with momentum um you know
there's going to be periods depending on
your chart that have lack of volume
right here like this bar right you got a
sell signal you know you got this nice
move up um bullish signal bullish signal
bullish signal bullish signal up here as
you're getting taking out the highs but
you got this one
bearish signal okay well it's coming in
on what the volume is it's kind of light
you know the the stopping volume reading
is 45% which is a strong number but the
volume I can just see the bar very thin
volume um in this bar it's only 147
contracts right whereas this previous
signal here there's a th000 contracts
over here it's 400 contracts this one's
only got 138 which is kind of light but
still you know
400 you know a
th000 you know so again you know like
there's this one's 54% but this is
actually I have the momentum filter on
that's why it's not showing but again
you know you want to take it on decent
volume this is a th000 contracts this
one here is 339 contracts okay so just
um you know understand that you know
when you're dealing with a um volume
based tool right trying to analyze
volume um you know the interesting thing
is you know obviously during data
release
is you get lighter volume Now sort of
the the interesting thing is is during
nighttime session you know if it's a
sort of a normal session if you're
looking at a range bar you know the
range bars tend to have decent volume
right unless someone you know some
Central Banker in Europe is speaking
there's a ECB announcement but when you
get to let's go back to the the timebase
chart here uh you know going back to
sort of that that European session
right you can see there you know there
signals coming in on very light volume
you know 27 contracts 26 um well that's
just before the European session here
but you know Europe's about to open
light volume obviously Europe just
opened you know 57 contracts yeah it
looks great because this next bar shot
up but again um you know you want to be
taking it on decent volume and again if
you're trading in the European session
that's just something that you have to
deal with is there's going to be times
of lighter volume right I mean do do you
know 63 is that a lot you know depending
on the time of day it might be 32 is
that a lot no um you know so just bear
that in mind because you it looks like
he could be starting a nice little move
here right but it's only 74 contracts
you know 154 65 then the heavy volume
comes starts coming in here 290 700
right and you see these bars have nice
volume 1,800 589 so just keep that in
mind you know when you're looking at
markets that trade thin volume at
certain times of the day um you know so
again if if I was looking at this is I'm
just showing you here in currencies if I
was looking at um currencies you know
I'd keep it to the main hours the main
us session hours um yeah I wouldn't go
past 2m
take a look at say crude oil
okay so I'm curious here as well on
crude okay so again decent signals crude
is is a market that has generally decent
volume right here's a nice move here
here's a nice move and again you know
people will say well this one the market
didn't go down but again you know I have
the momentum filter on so I'm looking
for the market to be moving down so even
though in general this Market is moving
down really what you got to be looking
for is in the next bar or two start
trading lower than the low of the bar
with stopping volume if it's not doing
that it's probably not going to be very
effective you know just as here right
you got a bullish signal but then the
next bar is trading lower should you
have taken this no this bar should be
trading this bar this bar should be
trading above just as here is a bullish
signal does because you have a bullish
signal does it mean you get long right
away no you should wait cuz you're
trading momentum that's the whole point
of using the momentum filter is to trade
on the right side of
momentum even though the market pulled
back and then started going up you know
you just wait here you know that 6690 is
the high of this bar where I had
stopping volume in this bar so I know
there was some supportive buying taking
place I want to make sure that it's
moving in my direction so you just wait
you know put in a buy stop at 91 just
above the high of this bar and you can
see hits 91 and continues on up into 10
11 eventually peeking out up here and
starting to reverse over here so that's
the stopping volume indicator it's a new
indicator on orderflows Trader 8 that is
is something that I would look at and
it's just sort of calculated in my head
for a long time but you know with this
new version of orderflows Trader it's
this is like a basically a standalone
indicator by itself and you know you
could actually add other pieces of order
flow to it some things like you know
imbalances is a great
uh sort of ingredient to add together
with it and other things like the Delta
change that uh I talked about yesterday
or even um some of these other Delta
numbers right just to uh further
strengthen what you're looking at in the
order flow so thanks everyone and I'll
see you guys on the next video